bonjour claude heureuse de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
alors ce ce premier verdict signifie
t'il selon vous la fin de la carrière
politique de la prix nobel de la paix
moi je crois que ça signifie d'abord que
la junte qui a pris le pouvoir il ya
neuf mois n'arrive pas à gouverner
vraiment la birmanie et ne sait pas
comment s'y prendre pour réaffirmer le
pouvoir de l'armée elle a pris le
pouvoir le 1er février dernier parce que
les élections qui avaient eu lieu en
neuf ans donné la majorité absolue aux
députés du parti créé par madame aung
san suu kyi et l'armée ne pouvaient pas
accepter cette nouvelle donne électorale
puisque l'article 1 du programme de ce
parti c'était de réformer la
constitution qui réservait un quart des
sièges dans les deux chambres du
parlement alarmé par conséquent l'armée
et risquer de perdre le pouvoir qu'elle
avait elle avait aussi d'autres
privilèges à savoir que le ministère de
la défense ministère de l'intérieur et
le ministère des territoires frontaliers
lui était dévolue et partez pas par
conséquent échapper complètement au
contrôle du gouvernement de madame aung
san suu kyi et puis par ailleurs il y
avait évidemment l'enjeu économique que
l'armée est aussi chef d'entreprise
contrôler un très grand nombre
d'entreprises elle est assise sur ce sur
ce magot et ne veut évidemment pas le
lâcher s'est prolongée hier à des
aspects les plus importants de
l'équation birmane alors elle vous
discréditez madame aung san suu kyi pour
la discréditer on l'accuse d'un de
malversations diverses et variées vous
avez énuméré les chefs d'accusation de
nombreux procès doivent se succéder on
dit qu'elle a calé corrompu on a trouvé
soi-disant 600000 euros on a trouvé de
l'or on l'a trouvé que l av
allez un certain nombre de lois y
compris en achetant des des talkie
walkie à l'étranger enfin tout et
n'importe quoi pour essayer de la
discréditer et d'ailleurs je pense que
les militaires sont pas mécontents que
une partie de ses partisans en occident
considère qu'elle a en fait mal jouer
sur l'héroïne gars puisqu'elle a laissé
faire les militaires qu'elle a même été
à à la cour internationale de justice
pour défendre la thèse officielle qui
était celle des militaires donc la
discréditer par tous les moyens c'est
une femme qui a aujourd'hui 75 ans qui a
un passé très important son père était
un militant pour l'indépendance sa mère
à continuer la lutte politique
elle a même été un temps
ambassadrice à new delhi ou dessous qui
a étudié pendant quelques années elle a
étudié quatre en quatre ans à oxford
quelques années aux états unis elle est
exactement l'inversé militaires qui
gouvernent ce pays elle est un tel à une
formation internationale les militaires
ne sont pratiquement jamais sortis de
leur pays et les uns ou les autres ont
gouverné comme des militaires pendant
environ 50 ans et concernant la junte
birmane est ce qu'elle envisage une
forme de transition politique et ce
qu'elles montrent des signes de
rapprochement avec les forces politiques
du pays alors on l'a cru on l'a cru
lorsque ils ont fait cette constitution
qui dans le font ressembler à une
ancienne constitution indonésienne qui
prévoyait une transition dans laquelle
on ménager une place à l'armée c'est ce
qui avait été fait et les pays
occidentaux ont cru que c'était vraiment
une transition mais pour les militaires
ça n'était pas une transition c'était
une un habillage assez habile d'ailleurs
dans lesquels on utilisait
la figure charismatique l'icône rousse
en dessous qui pour donner une
coloration civile un gouvernement qui
restait fondamentalement militaire et
donc en effet ils n'ont aucune envie
aucune intention de lâcher ce pouvoir et
notamment le pouvoir économique
simplement le pays est en très mauvais
état aujourd'hui les banques ont dû
arrêter de fonctionner pendant plusieurs
mois et ce pays qui est riche qui a
beaucoup de ressources naturelles en
réalité est mis en coupe réglée par
cette junte militaire qui n'a aucune
aucune intention de donner aussi avec
avec le poids pour aboutir à un pouvoir
civil et qui a aussi deux les plus
grandes difficultés à traiter les
minorités ethniques qui sont très
nombreuses et qui se sont révoltés
contre ce pouvoir militaire qui veut une
centralisation accrue alors très court
claudie nous reste une minute est ce que
ce procès peut déclencher une réaction
internationale de quel pays de ken block
et sous quelle forme finale oui sûrement
le jour où il y aura à une condamnation
une première condamnation puisqu'il ya
d'autres procès en cours il y aura
certainement une réaction internationale
bien sûr c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs que le verdict a été reporté
a été reporté au mois de décembre
on attendra probablement la proche des
fêtes de noël pour annoncer un verdict
et la suite des autres procès mais je
pense qu'il y aura une réaction
importante y compris en france
d'ailleurs madame dessous qui est
citoyenne d'honneur de la ville de paris
très bien on va suivre cela évidemment
merci beaucoup clown c'est l édito
diplomatique de la matinale de rtl
france